TO THE HOSPITAL OR FILL UP BEDS.
>> Trace: WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE,
THANK YOU.
>> Sandra: TOUGH ANY
CONSEQUENCES FOR THOSE IN THE
LOCKDOWN HYPOCRISY HALL OF FAME.
THE MAYOR OF AUSTIN ON A
MEXICAN VACATION WHEN HE TOLD
HIS CONSTITUENTS TO STAY HOME
TO STOP THE SPREAD OF COVID.
HE SAID HE WAS SORRY FOR THAT.
MY NEXT GUEST SAYS THE APOLOGY
DOES NOT GO FAR ENOUGH AND IS
NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
GOVERNOR MIKE HUCKABEE HERE IN
HIS OWN WORDS.
THE FORMER ARKANSAS GOVERNOR
AND FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR JOINS
US NOW.
GOVERNOR, IT WAS TOUGH TO TAKE
A LOT OF THOSE INSTANCES OF
HYPOCRISY.
DOES SORRY CUT IT?
>> NO, IT DOESN’T.
I’LL TELL YOU WHY.
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE LOST THEIR
JOBS.
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHOSE KIDS ARE
HAVING TO STAY HOME FROM SCHOOL
ARE MISSING THEIR WORK BECAUSE
THEY CAN’T GO TO WORK.
THEY HAVE TO STAY HOME AND TAKE
CARE OF KIDS BECAUSE SCHOOLS
ARE CLOSED.
THE HYPOCRISY IS TERRIBLE.
WHO HASN’T MISSED A SINGLE
PAYCHECK PEOPLE WORKING IN
GOVERNMENT, CITY, STATE,
FEDERAL GOT EVERY PAYCHECK.
HERE IS WHAT WE NEED TO DO.
THESE MAYORS AND GOVERNORS WHO
HAVE ORDERED PEOPLE TO MISS
THEIR JOBS, LET THEM TAKE A PAY
CUT.
LET THEM DO WITHOUT THEIR PAY
FOR A MONTH AND SAY I’M NOT
GOING TO ASK YOU TO DO
SOMETHING THAT I’M NOT WILLING
TO DO.
THAT WOULD BE ONE THING.
AND THE FACT IS JUST GLARING
HYPOCRISY.
WHAT IT REVEALS IS THIS.
THESE PEOPLE DON’T BELIEVE IN A
LOCKDOWN.
THEY DON’T BELIEVE THAT SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND WEARING A MASK
WORKS.
IF IT DID THEY WOULD BE DOING
IT.
INSTEAD THEY WANT TO IMPOSE
THESE RESTRICTIONS ON OTHER
PEOPLE.
PERSONALLY I BELIEVE WE OUGHT
TO BE WEARING MASKS AND SOCIAL
DISTANCING AND I’M NOT ORDERING
OTHER PEOPLE TO DO IT.
I’M DOING IT BECAUSE IT’S THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THESE FOLKS WHO ARE ORDERING IT
AND NOT DOING IT SHOULD RESIGN.
>> Sandra: AND GOVERNOR I THINK
SO MANY PEOPLE WATCHING AND
LISTENING TO YOU RIGHT NOW
AGREE WE’RE ALL TRYING TO DO
WHAT WE CAN TO STAY SAFE.
YOU SEE THE SHATTERING OF LIVES
AND BUSINESSES THAT’S HAPPENING
RIGHT NOW AND AGAIN ANOTHER
MULTI-WEEK SHUTDOWN IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND THEN TO HAVE ADMIRAL ON
THIS PROGRAM SAYING THERE IS NO
SCIENCE BEHIND THE OUTDOOR
RESTAURANT SHUTDOWN.
HE DIDN’T SAY THAT NEEDS TO
HAPPEN.
IT IS NOT ESSENTIAL TO STOP THE
SPREAD TO SHUT DOWN THE OUTDOOR
DINING.
WHAT IS GOING ON HERE?
>> I THINK IT’S NOT ABOUT
CONTROLLING THE VIRUS, IT IS
ABOUT CONTROLLING THE
POPULATION.
IT IS ABOUT PEOPLE EXHIBITING
THEIR POWER AND BEING POWER
CRAZY.
THE SAD THING IS A LOT OF
PEOPLE ARE GOING ALONG WITH IT.
IN CALIFORNIA CHURCHES WERE
TOLD THEY COULDN’T HAVE MORE
THAN 10 PEOPLE IN THE CHURCH.
NOW YOU CAN GO TO A STRIP CLUB.
I JOKINGLY SUGGESTED ON SEAN
HANNITY’S PROGRAM PASTORS OUGHT
TO STAND UP AND SAY THEY’LL
OPEN A STRIP CLUB FOR CHURCH.
STRIP OFF THEIR TIE AND HAVE AS
MANY PEOPLE AS THEY WANTED.
SOME CALIFORNIA PASTORS
ACTUALLY DID THAT.
ROB MCCOY HAD GOD SPEAK CALVARY
CHAPEL IN THOUSAND OAKS.
IT WAS HILARIOUS BUT MADE THE
POINT.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO SAY IT’S SO
DANGEROUS TO HAVE MORE THAN 10
PEOPLE BE CONSISTENT.
AND THAT’S NOT WHAT IS
HAPPENING.
AND I HEAR THIS ALL THE TIME.
LET’S LISTEN TO THE SCIENCE.
OKAY, LET’S LISTEN TO THE
SCIENCE.
THE SCIENCE DOESN’T TELL US
THAT OUTDOOR DINING IS REALLY
HARMFUL.
SO WHY ARE WE DOING IT?
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
GOVERNMENT BUREAUCRAT OR
ELECTED OFFICIAL WHO HAS IT IN
HIS HEAD HE IS A PRINCE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IS A PEASANT AND
IT IS DISGUSTING.
IT IS IMMORAL AND IT IS NOT HOW
WE ARE SUPPOSED TO BE AS A
COUNTRY WHERE OUR PUBLIC
SERVANTS ARE TO SERVE US, NOT
US SERVE THEM.
>> Sandra: GOVERNOR, WE HAVE
SORT OF A LIST OF THOSE WHO
MADE THE HALL OF FAME FOR THE
HYPOCRISY WE’VE KEPT TRACK OF.
THE STORY OF NEWSOM, THE
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA PICTURED
IN THE FANCY RESTAURANT, FRENCH
LAUNDRY.
THE SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR WAS
SEATED AT THE SAME RESTAURANT.
WE TALKED ABOUT THE AUSTIN
MAYOR.
GOVERNOR, I HEAR YOU SAY YOU
ARE SHOCKED BY HOW MANY PEOPLE
JUST GO ALONG WITH THE TOUGH
RESTRICTIONS.
WHAT ARE PEOPLE SUPPOSED TO DO?
THEY WANT TO ABIDE BY THE LAW
AND NOT HIT BY FINES.
THEY DON’T WANT TO BE
TROUBLEMAKERS.
THEY WANT TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
WHAT ARE YOU SUGGESTING BY THAT?
>> WELL, I WOULD SUGGEST THAT
THEY DO WHAT THEY BELIEVE IS
THE RIGHT THING.
THEY ARE FREE AMERICANS.
WE AREN’T LIVING UNDER TYRANNY
HERE.
I THINK SOME PEOPLE MAY FEEL
LIKE WE ARE COMING TO THAT.
BE RESPONSIBLE.
AS I SAID BEFORE, I’M TAKING
ALL THE STEPS THAT WE’RE TOLD
TO TAKE BUT I’M NOT DOING IT
BECAUSE SOME TYRANT IS TELLING
ME I HAVE TO.
I’M DOING IT BECAUSE I WANT TO
PROTECT MYSELF, MY FAMILY AND
FRIENDS AND THE PEOPLE I BUMP
INTO.
I DON’T HAVE TO BE ORDERED TO
DO IT.
BUT PEOPLE OUGHT TO HAVE SOME
FREEDOM IN THIS COUNTRY AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
GOING TO CHURCH.
IT’S RIDICULOUS TO SAY YOU CAN
GO TO A BIG BOX STORE AND BUMP
SHOULDERS WITH HUNDREDS OF
STRANGERS AND TOUCH THE ITEMS
THEY JUST TOUCHED BUT YOU CAN’T
GO TO CHURCH AND SIT AND SING A
HYMN BECAUSE IT MAY BE WAY
WORSE THAN GOING TO A STRIP
CLUB, CASINO, OR A BIG DISCOUNT
STORE.
IT MAKES NO SENSE AT ALL.
THERE HAS TO BE CONSISTENCY.
THE FACT THAT THERE ISN’T IS
CAUSING PEOPLE TO BECOME
CYNICAL.
THAT’S A REAL PUBLIC HEALTH
RISK WHEN WE GET CYNICAL AND WE
DON’T BELIEVE ANYTHING OUR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS TELL US.
>> Sandra: EMOTIONS ARE RUNNING
SO HIGH.
WE’RE ABOUT TO GET THE UPDATE
ON THE BAR OWNER DEFYING THE
TOUGH RESTRICTIONS IN THE NEW
YORK CITY AREA.
STATEN ISLAND THE BAR OWNER,
HIS STORY, GETTING ARRESTED FOR
DEFYING THE RESTRICTIONS.
YOU JUST WONDER WHAT POINT THIS
ALL GETS TO.
EVERY DAY YOU THINK WE’VE
REACHED THE MAX CAPACITY THAT
WE CAN HANDLE AND NOW THIS
MULTI-WEEK SHUTDOWN IN
CALIFORNIA.
GOVERNOR, ALWAYS APPRECIATE